albert cohen publie ses mots en 1972 il
relate une histoire son histoire celle
de ses 10 ans depuis le 18 novembre
samir siad les lie à des lycéens pour
sensibiliser à l'antisémitisme
on parle de lecture mais dans tous les
sens du terme c'est à dire à la fois une
lecture à voix haute
on fait passer les mots des auteurs mais
aussi une lecture dans le champ d'une
interprétation donc forcément et a
fortiori face à de tels textes on peut
pas rester indifférent
des lectures lancé par le théâtre
montansier une vingtaine de lycées lino
à l'accueil en novembre et en mars le
programme scolaire des lycéens faits qui
sont sensibilisés
avec tout ce qui s'est passé pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale etc
il aborde le sujet avec plus de notion
donc c'est plus facile de diriger vers
eux d'autant que ces textes sont très
porteurs à albert cohen se joint primo
levi qui témoigne de sa survie à
auschwitz
une lecture d'une heure suivi d'un
échange entre jamais comédien c'était
très émouvant
on voit que certaines personnes peuvent
vraiment se reconnaître dans le rôle du
petit garçon ça m'a touché parce qu'on
retrouve vraiment le cours de dents en
fait c'est
c'est vraiment la même chose que ce que
le prof nous raconte c'est vraiment une
histoire sincère ça ça dénonce vraiment
le racisme on espère bien évidemment
avoir l'occasion par la suite de
sensibiliser nos élèves à d'autres types
de discriminations et à faire en sorte
que le vivre ensemble se diffuse le
mieux possible
plus de 2500 élèves seront ainsi
sensibilisés sur ces deux périodes
d'intervention
après deux années de recul les actes
antisémites ont augmenté de 74% en 2018